- [Instructor] Let's
talk a little bit about
the conservation of angular momentum.
And this is going to be really useful,
because it explains diverse
phenomena in the universe.
From why an ice skater's
angular speed goes up
when they tuck their arms or
their legs in, all the way to
when you have something
orbiting around a star,
and the closer and closer it spirals in,
it seems like its rotational
velocity's angular speed
is picking up.
And it starts to rotate faster
and faster around the body.
You'll see that if you see simulations
of astronomical phenomena.
So the big picture here is,
is if we have our initial angular momentum
for a system, and we'll think
about that a little bit.
As long as the system has no
external torque applied to it,
then your final angular
momentum is going to be
the exact same thing.
And so, one way to think about it,
let's imagine that I have some type of
spinning thing over here.
I have some type of mass,
let's say it's on a table,
I'm looking from above, and a point on
the outside of this disk is
spinning in this direction,
with a velocity of magnitude v.
And let's say that there's a
clump of clay, of orange...
Maybe it's Play Doh, or clay or something.
And it has a velocity
going in this direction.
It's on a collision
course with this object.
And let's say it has a velocity of 5v.
And so, if we think about
this disk-clay clump system,
and so you always have
to specify what system
you are talking about,
so if you think about this entire system,
how does the angular momentum change
before these two things collide,
and then after these two things collide?
So actually, let me draw the
after the collision scenario.
So the after the collision scenario,
it looks something like this,
where the clay has now clumped onto this,
and now they are going
to be rotating together.
And I haven't even told
you the mass of this disk,
or the mass of this clay,
so it would be unclear in which direction
they would now be rotating.
But how is the angular
momentum going to change
from this state, from the initial state,
to the final state?
Pause this video and
try to think about it.
Well, you might have guessed.
Since we said, look, we
have this whole system,
and we're not applying any
external torque to the system,
our angular momentum is going
to stay exactly the same.
Now, we have to be careful.
If I told you the system
was just this disk,
not the clay clump that's on
a collision course with it,
then the angular momentum
for the disk would change,
but why is that?
Does that defy the conservation
of angular momentum?
No.
Because this clay clump, when it collides,
would be providing an
external torque to the system,
if we defined the system
to just be the disk.
But since it's the disk
plus the clay clump,
and we have no external torque
to that combined system,
then our angular momentum
is not going to change.
Now that we can appreciate
that angular momentum is constant
as long as that there is no net torque
applied to the system,
let's think about the famous
situation where an ice skater's
angular speed goes up as
they tuck in their arms.
And you can do a less
graceful version of this
on an office chair,
where if you sit on the office
chair and you begin spinning,
this is my office chair, and
if you stick your legs out,
at first you're going to spin slowly,
but then if you tuck your legs in,
you're gonna start spinning faster.
You're gonna have a higher angular speed.
Now, why is that?
Well, to appreciate
that, we can think about
the formula for angular momentum.
So the formula for angular momentum, L,
there's a couple of ways we can,
or several ways that we can write that.
We can write that as our
moment of inertia, I,
times our angular speed.
Times omega.
And this might look a little
bit foreign at first to you,
but it has a complete analog
when we're dealing in the linear world.
Here we're rotating.
In the linear world, we
say that linear momentum
is equal to mass,
is equal to mass times velocity.
And the reason why we have an analog here,
is mass can tell you about
inertia of an object.
How much force do you need to apply
to accelerate that object?
f equals ma.
Well, moment of inertia,
you have something similar going on.
But instead of thinking
about how to just linearly
accelerate something,
this tells you how hard is it
to get angular acceleration,
how much torque do you need to apply?
Instead of just how much linear force
you need to apply.
And instead of velocity,
you have angular speed,
and sometimes this is called
angular velocity as well.
But this by itself, you might say,
well this doesn't help
me on tucking in my knees
when I'm on an office chair,
or the ice skater tucking in her arms.
Well, to think about that,
we just have to appreciate
that the moment of inertia
can be expressed as
m times radius squared, m r squared.
And then we still have
our omega right over here.
So this is another way of
writing angular momentum.
And so, when a skater tucks in her arms,
her mass is not changing,
that is staying constant.
But remember, the radius,
one way to think about it,
it's a little complicated
when you're thinking about
a human body system.
In a simple sense you
just have a point mass
rotating around a point like that,
then this is the radius.
But if we're dealing with a
more complicated structure,
like a human body,
you can imagine the
radius as being indicative
of the average distance of the mass,
from the center of rotation.
So when the figure
skater tucks in her arms,
that average distance goes down.
And so when she tucks in
her arm, this goes down,
but if this part goes down,
but our angular momentum
stays constant, because we have no torque
being applied to the system,
no net torque being applied to the system,
well then, this needs to
go up in order to keep
that angular momentum constant.
And that's exactly what's happening.
The angular speed picks up,
just as the radius goes down.
Now, this also explains why if you have,
let's say that's some type of planet,
and you have a rock, or
something orbiting it.
As this gets closer and
closer to the planet,
it's angular speed is going to go higher,
and higher, and higher.
Why is that?
Well, because when you have a high radius,
so here your radius is higher,
and so your angular speed
might be a little bit lower,
but then when you're closer
in, your radius has gone down.
And so your angular speed has
to go up to make up for it.
I'll leave you there.
I encourage you to have fun
spinning on office chairs.